jour je vais commencer par me présenter
mais avant cela j'aimerais citer une
sagesse africaine qui nous dit que
lorsqu'on vous demande d'appeler vous
appelez le nom que vous connaissiez le
nom est un mot magique en fait dans nos
sociétés africaines traditionnelles
chaque nom avait une signification
[Musique]
chaque nom était une histoire
moi je m'appelle nadine christelle andré
bis qui n'a je n'ai pas eu la chance
d'avoir de ces noms qui ont une
signification particulière qui revêt un
symbole qui raconte ce qui s'est passé
le jour de ma naissance
ou qui annonce un événement
même et prénoms sont jolies n'est ce pas
nadine christelle andré c'est peut-être
pour cela que mes parents les ont donnés
mais au delà de mes prénom qui suis-je
quel est mon identité
est ce que vous êtes déjà posé cette
question
c'est une question qui paraît simple une
question existentielle que d'ailleurs
chacun d'entre nous devraient se poser à
un moment de sa vie si vous l'avez pas
encore fait je vous invite à le faire
maintenant avec moi qui sommes nous
si je me suis posé cette question c'est
parce que j'ai cru comprendre
par itr est il
que pour savoir où l'on va il faudrait
savoir d'où l'on vient
cela sous-entend
que pour dessiner son avenir
il faudrait pouvoir trouver son identité
réelle
notre identité profonde a donc une
influence sur notre parcours a une
influence sur la réussite de nos projets
une influence sur notre avenir pour
bâtir un avenir il faudrait répondre à
cette question complexe
qui suis-je
j'avoue que moi je me suis posé la
question mais j'ai pas pu répondre elle
est trop compliqué
donc je me suis posé une autre question
comment est ce que mes racines peuvent
influencer mon avenir
dites moi comment est-ce que des actions
des décisions des moeurs des batailles
auxquelles je n'ai pas participé il ya
des milliers d'années peuvent avoir une
influence sur mes rêves
là toute la substance de mes propos cet
après midi
comment est-ce que ce que nous sommes
peut nous permettre de réinventer
l'avenir c'est cela c'est le thème n'est
ce pas
comme vous tous moi j'ai j'ai des rêves
j'ai des aspirations j'ai des projets
j'ai des ambitions et pour réaliser mes
projets c'est très simple il me suffit
de lire n'importe quels livres de
développement personnel
ou bien de suivre une vidéo d'un coach
sur youtube sur what's app ils me diront
tous la même chose il faut de la
persévérance
il faut une vision il faut avancer il
faut travailler dur il faut oser
il faut il faut de la passion il faut de
l'amour fou de la patience
[Musique]
mais dis donc
mes origines
les origines de mes parents de mes
grands parents de mes arrière grands
parents n'ont donc aucun impact
sur mon avenir
les batailles gagnées ou perdues du roi
makoko l'organisation du royaume congo
ne peuvent pas influencer mes rêves
aujourd'hui
que je m'appelle nadine elisabeth
fatimata binta wind à
nankin en effet aucun impact
sur ma réussite
[Musique]
que je sois végétarienne
que je mange je vous fous du fonio de la
tchèque et de la classe a ou des pommes
de terre frites
ne change rien à la façon dont je mène
des projet
que je porte clairement le pagne ou que
je m'habille en tailleur pantalon
n'a pas d'impact sur ma carrière
professionnelle en tout cas pour
l'instant
et pour vous dire même si monkey congo
mon lingala ne sont pas corrects n'est
ce pas
cela n'a pas
d'effet sur ma carrière professionnelle
pourtant on me dit que pour savoir où je
vais il faut que je sache d'où je viens
on me dit que pour voir pousser les
fruits il faut arroser ses racines à
moi j'ai l'impression sur la pâte sens
en fait cela n'a pas de sens parce que
là j'ai mené ma réflexion de façon
individuelle personnelle moi mes projets
mais rêve
ma carrière professionnelle
mais si je mène cette réflexion de façon
globale
collective
déjà je me poserai une question
différente
la question sera comment est ce que
l'afrique le continent auquel
j'appartiens
peut bâtir
son avenir en s'appuyant sur son
identité profonde et là tout est
complètement différent
pourtant vous avez l'identité de
l'afrique ce sont nos identités
ce sont nos identités personnelles
individuelles mises ensemble c'est la
conjugaison de nos identités qui veulent
identité de l'afrique et donc si
aujourd'hui certains
pensent que l'identité de l'afrique
a l'air plus moi
bricoler
à l'air plus ou moins
emprunté
mais c'est peut-être parce que nos
identités à nous aussi le son
empreinte et
bricoler
pourtant pour que l'afrique puisse
trouver son chemin sa voie il faudrait
qu'elle et son identité
locale puisse avancer avec tout ce
qu'elle subit il faudrait qu'elle puisse
trouver son identité profonde
réel
afin qu'elle ne soit pas celle qui
continue à suivre à faire du mimétisme
ou à mendier pour atteindre une réalité
qui n'est pas la sienne
[Musique]
il faudrait qu'elle se retrouve
nous n'avons donc pas d'autre choix que
de mettre nos identités personnelles au
service de l'identité collective
ce n'est que comme cela que l'afrique
pourra retrouver son identité c'est en
nous appuyant sur notre socle commun sur
notre héritage
commun l'héritage de nos ancêtres
que nous pourrons retrouver
notre identité
voyez vous
aujourd'hui
nos enfants
sont influencés par les dynasties
japonaise le manga et autres îles il
aimerait devenir des samouraïs des
ninjas et autre chose
mais tout simplement parce que personne
ne leur a dit qu'elle était la force et
la puissance des armes et de samory
touré ou de son attaque et à
comment voulez vous qu'ils soient fiers
de ressembler à ce qu'ils ne connaissent
pas
comme je les dis plus haut nous n'avons
pas d'autre choix
nous devons mettre nos identités
personnelles au service de l'identité
collective en nous appuyant sur nos
attributs culturels carton qui aura d
elisabeth des nadine d isabelle en
afrique tant que nos enfants les prénoms
de nos enfants seront inspirés par les
telenovelas par les feux de l'amour ou
par d'autres mutants
nous n'aurons pas d'identité
temps que les africains qui se disent
panafricain seront fiers d'aborder des
passeports américains canadiens
français
on ne nous reconnaîtra plus
tant que les africains seront hors de
l'afrique
au service
de ceux qui nous ont asservi
en ne nous respectera pas
tant que nous ne porterons nos tenues
traditionnelles
uniquement que pour des événements
spéciaux on ne nous admirera pas
tant que nous ne pourrons pas
communiquer entre nous autrement qu'en
utilisant une langue étrangère
on ne comprendra pas
en fait tant que nous ne serons pas nous
mêmes
nous ne pourrons pas exister dans ce
monde globalisé
dans cette civilisation de l'universel
il faudrait que nous apportons notre
particularité
afin de ne pas être invisible
et pour cela il faut pas couper le
cordon il est trop riche
maintenant lorsque j'ai dit ça qu'est ce
qu'on fait
qu'est ce qu'on va faire parce que mon
dieu
ça paraît difficile mais combien
d'années nous votera pour y arriver
mais moi je pense que non je pense que
non parce que déjà ça a déjà commencé
je pense que non parce qu'il ya des
exemples il y en a beaucoup mais je
prendrai des exemples qu'on connaît tous
le rwanda bien que naviguant entre deux
langues étrangères
le quine à rwanda est la langue
officielle
moi qui viens j'étais à deux semaines le
gouverneur rwanda et parler dans les
administrations dans les réunions dans
les conférences le burkina faso qui a
fait la promotion du tissu burkinabè est
fabriqué avec des matériels locaux avec
des matières premières locales et
beaucoup d'autres exemples notre
jeunesse a compris j allais sur les
réseaux sociaux ils cherchent ils
veulent il cherchera mes qualités
et eux ils font leur part n'est ce pas
et chacun devrait faire sa part chacun
devrait faire sa part pour apprendre
pour comprendre pour transmettre pour
partager pour encourager les bonnes
initiatives pour consommer
ce n'est que comme cela que nous allons
y arriver
mais ça avait un célèbre historien
joseph ki zerbo dans son message à la
jeunesse juste avant sa mort
disait chaque génération à des pyramides
à construire
chaque appli cas ici et maintenant
devrait être une valeur ajoutée
soyons tous une valeur ajoutée pour
notre afrique
[Applaudissements]